[Musique]
les gros patine bien ça a été conçu et
joué par olivier martin salvan et pierre
guillois qui se sont amusés à caen sur
cette folie qui est digne des monty
python on venait d'assurer une sorte de
road trip
d'épopée qui nous amène de l'islande à
au sud de l'espagne
[Musique]
mine de rien adaptation du chef-d'oeuvre
de la mgm qui avait été fait ce film
musical qui avait été réalisé en 1952 là
c'est une adaptation pour la scène par
un ensemble qui s'appelle ars lyrique à
une adaptation extrêmement fidèle au
film drôle le film raconte l'histoire du
passage du muet du film muet du cinéma
muet au cinéma parlant sur scène c'est
ou en fosse d'orchestre et 50 musiciens
chanteurs danseurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
youssoupha dans une forme très
particulière donc le rappeur youssoupha
et qui avait été révélée au public par
l'album noir désir je crois que c'était
il ya dix ou 10 ou 11 ans et qui va
revisiter ses 20 ans de carrière et ses
vingt ans de rap avec spectacle
s'appelle youssoupha gospel expérience
sur scène un choeur gospel et 24
musiciens classiques
[Musique]